Incoming time flux
Now
I thought I had more time
The Universe is a complex piece of machinery and balance must be maintained
One change requires another
How would you propose that I keep the balance
will you help me save Barry and Cara or not?
Tell me what you need in exchange, whatever the multiverse requires to survive the crisis that is looming
Tell me what you need in exchange,
whatever the multiverse requires to survive the crisis that is looming
So it barked and Mme
what does the multiverse require you assist me as we seek to prevent the inevitable that that
Sounds impossible. The multiverse is more complex than you could fathom
what does the multiverse require
you assist me as we seek to prevent the inevitable
that sounds impossible.
The multiverse is more complex than you could fathom
What are you not telling me?
I've seen your future, Oliver, inexorable and unavoidable. I have watched you die
During this crisis?
I am truly sorry
No.....You are not taking him, Oliver-
I'm not here to bring harm to you or your daughter. Trust me the world needs her
Do you think that I'm just gonna let you leave here with my husband's life?
This is bigger than us than all of us
~why does it always have to be you?~
I cannot prevent his passing but he can prevent the death of countless more easily you and your daughter
There's actually a pretty small audience that just watches everything. You may just watch 1 or 2 of the TV shows
Hi everyone, its charlie, so we got to talk about the Flash season 6 teaser,all the post-credits scenes for crisis on Infinite Earths on all the-
-Arrowverse shows arrow season 7, finale the Legends finale, the Supergirl finale
So it's gonna be way bigger and they're breaking it into two different parts one will start in December like the normal
crossovers do and then the second part will be in January when all the shows come back and
It's all about the end of arrow arrows final season
So obviously we're all expecting Oliver to be the one to die instead of Barry because of this bargain that he made with the monitor
And that gets into the Arrow post-credit scene I didn't include everything from the arrow scene so i will explain the Felicity part of that too at the very end of the episode
But if you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe to get all the DC easter-egg videos
There's gonna be a bunch of big stuff coming this fall. We have Batman, Deathstroke, Ravager and Superboy coming to Titan
So there's a bunch of DC Universe stuff happening separately, but that's all separate universe from the Arrowverse stuff
We'll do a new round of the giveaway for the DC Universe subscription. All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment about one of the Crisis episodes on the video
I've already seen the first episode of Swamp Thing I'm allowed to do a non-spoilery video this Friday
So we'll be talking about Swamp Thing later this week
First big scene the Flash season 6 post credits scenes
So obviously they changed the timeline Reverse-flash got Nora to make a whole bunch of changes erasing herself
But allowing him to escape from prison. He tells Barry see you at the next crisis-
-because he is from the Future, he knows how Flash vanishes in Crisis on Infinite Earth but he might not know about every single change that just happened
So the wrench in his plan might have something to do with what Oliver is doing with the monitor
That's sort of the new thing that's throwing a wrinkle into all of this-
but in present day, the only thing that has changed about Crisis is that the future newspaper date has rolled back to the date of this year's crossover
It's still happening during 2019. So whoever vanishes, Arrow or the Flash still happens at the end of this year
You know what that probably means there's gonna be a huge cliffhanger
One of the heroes will die during the big third act climax
Then they will have an epilogue, probably for Oliver, when the second part comes back in January
Don't forget - there's only 10 episodes in the final season of arrow and it sounds like based on the monitor grabbing him saying that
The multiverse needs you right now
we need to start right now that all of the episodes of arrow season 8 will be
crisis episodes if you have not been watching arrow they've been doing
Flash-forwards this year with a future version of Roy a future version of the heroes
Oliver's daughter and Connor hawke who sort of like the future team arrow
Will probably get more of them coming back - so it will just be crisis on Infinite Earths
They'll find a way to sort of tease what happens before it actually happens using those flash forwards
During the arrow finale post-credits scene Oliver is sitting there after his baby, Mia, has been born the monitor shows up
This is a couple months after the end of the events of the arrow finale
They dealt with that in the first half of the episode
Then the second half of the episode was all this crisis stuff that they were setting up
He shows up and says we need to go right now dude multiverses falling down all over the place that bargain you made
Yeah, we need to do whatever the multiverse requires so he doesn't say exactly what Oliver needs to do
But but I think it's implied ultimately it will mean him
Sacrificing his life so that Barry and Kara can live they even did the flashback to show you a longer
version of that bargain scene that he made during last year's crossover. So that's happening in present day
So while the present day of flash season six and all the other shows are happening
They have the regular plots, Oliver will be off traversing the multiverse doing all of his stuff trying to get ready for crisis
There was another scene with the monitor in an old version of felicity in the future that I did not include in this video
So what happens is is that after they sort of saved this city in the future
The future team arrow has officially taken over for original team Arrow
Felicity says goodbye to her children - Mia natural born daughter and to William her stepson
They meet at Oliver's grave
Then she summons the monitor who takes her into the afterlife to be with Oliver again
So just more evidence that he dies during crisis on Infinite Earths
But just remembered that the afterlife in the DC comic book universe is different from the afterlife in other TV show universes
So just because he dies during the crossover doesn't mean that other alternate-universe versions of oliver can't come back
So stephen amell can guest star in future crossovers or they could always bring back force ghosts oliver during future
crossovers to be part of whatever they do in future seasons
as long as the arrow verse continues to be a thing think of him as the Yoda of the arrow verse going forward ah young
Skywalker Barry Allen how I have missed you there was a legends of tomorrow scene where the monitor shows up in the background
He doesn't do anything
He's just sitting there watching their show eating some popcorn with the book of destiny to remind you who he is
And that he was a big part of the crossover last year because last year Legends did not do the crossover
They made a joke about that during the legends finale, but he didn't really have any big scene during the legends episode
So don't worry about that, but the legends will be part of crisis on Infinite Earths. Remember they're doing a five-part crossover
So it's all 5 shows. It's Flash, Arrow, Legends of Tomorrow
Supergirl and the Batwoman TV show don't really know what that woman is gonna be doing during the crossover
We'll find out about that later this year
The Supergirl post-credit scene is a little more interesting because it's the monitor collecting a couple of really big powerful
villains and it seems like he's either gonna make them work with the heroes to save the multiverse or if this is a
different version of the monitor a rogue Monitor
and he's working against the multiverse, then he's using them to destroy it or do something crazy
But it seems like unless we get some more information
That it's the same monitor and he's gonna make them work with the heroes
even if you're not sure who Martian Manhunter
'he's evil brother is you probably picked up from this scene that he's coming for him to get revenge for locking him up for all
These years if you're not a big comic book reader Martian Manhunter has an evil brother named Ma'alefa'ak who tried to release this really
Crazy, bio agent harming a whole bunch of their people Martian Manhunter defeated him and locked him up in an interdimensional prison
So the monitor using his crazy level of power is releasing him saying I need you to get revenge on your brother
but it also probably need him to do something as part of this big crisis crossover -
part of the reason for doing that I think from a story perspective is is because Martian Manhunter as a character is so
overpowered that he becomes a big problem for stories because he's basically as strong as Supergirl
But he can also phase everything and he's telepathic and he's ancient so he has way more
Fighting in battle experience than someone say like Supergirl who's also super powerful
but you need somebody who's capable of fighting Martian Manhunter who has abilities that are powerful as his so
That's really why you bring in an evil brother who has the exact same abilities?
Reverse-flash kind of seems like he's his own agent of chaos in all this obviously
He's just trying to manipulate things to his own benefit
There was the teaser in Nora's future newspaper that says reverse-flash leading army of shadow demons
A lot of people are like are those time rays? Those are the shadow demons that are referred to in the newspaper
That's always possible that that's who they are. But because they're changing so much from the comics about crisis on Infinite Earths
It's hard to say whether or not the anti-monitor will be the real main villain or if it will be some other person
Because you remember the monitors are basically gods respective to the other characters in the DC Universe
So don't forget that there are many monitors living in the multiverse
the one that we've been seeing is just one of them so it's possible that we see some of the other
Monitors flying around but I'm guessing that for the most part we'll just be following this one
What'll probably happen is is that when they do the Comic Con?
Trailers for all the TV shows like the flash Comic Con trailer the arrow final season Comic Con trailer
They'll have some way of teasing crisis on Infinite Earths during those because they're spending so much time
Building up to this huge huge crossover. I'm not really planning on doing Batwoman videos this fall for that TV show
I'll be doing Titans videos. And if you're a big Batman fan, he'd rather see Batman than see Bat-woman
He's gonna be on Titan season 2 played by Jorah Mormont from Game of Thrones
But Bab woman is going to be airing back-to-back with Supergirl on Sunday nights
So if you're a Supergirl person and you really like that show they're making bat woman for you
But my Sunday night show this fall starting in November is basically gonna be Rick and Morty's season four so I'll be busy doing videos
For that instead of doing bat woman videos. I feel like everybody will probably be okay with that. We also have the Star Wars
Mandalorian TV series, The Witcher
Netflix TV series in a whole bunch of other really big stuff that's starting later this year the Disney Plus streaming service
So I'll just remind everyone when they drop footage. No worries
There's a lot of really cool stuff coming up while you wait for everything. Click here for all my Avengers endgame Easter eggs and
Spider-man far from home trailer videos and click here for my Game of Thrones finale video. Thank you so much for watching everybody
Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight